hello welcome to nightmare of decay
why are they barking
why are the puppies barking
doesn't matter we're in it now hello
you look weird
23 year old Judith glaslow was reported
missing yesterday evening she is
described as Caucasian five foot seven
inches tall with a slim build and long
brown hair
she was last seen entering her apartment
after being escorted home by friends
following a late night out clubbing now
I'm sorry I don't know
please searched her apart I know it's
supposed to be a scary game I apologize
and interviewed neighbors but have been
unable to find any clues leading to her
current whereabouts is is my close
friends and the relatives say the
Glasgow glaslow had been complaining
about frequent nightmares and
hallucinations in the days before she
went missing it is unknown if if these
had anything to do with their
disappearance
Vietnam is not glaslow is the latest in
an alarming number of recent
disappearances that have local residents
spooked authorities say there have been
over 10 missing people reported in just
the past week
police have been unable to find any new
leads in their investigation of the
disappearances and implore anyone with
more information to call the missing
persons investigative unit at oh no and
not only do they have things to say
about it but also these people have
something to say about it
overwhelmingly positive anyway just the
glowing reviews of this game
this one freaking hair wants to be
literally in my eye
that didn't help at all all right good
enough whatever it's at least marginally
better you turn off the TV you've been
having terrible nightmares recently and
watching the news about these
disappearances just gonna make them
worse and also you're gonna disappear
because they have nightmares too it's
getting late and you're feeling pretty
tired you should eat dinner and take a
shower before going to bed you're pretty
sure that there was a leftover slice of
pizza in the fridge ooh very scary pizza
look around using the mouse hey look I'm
fine time to get some pizza
love the cutscene this [ __ ] hair is
back
one little strand
tab to access your inventory hover over
whoa it is like Resident Evil
oh all right right Mouse to use yum
there's nothing to use it on
you can use it on my mouth do I need to
look in the mirror to be able to eat
food do I need to know where it goes
because I keep forgetting maybe I heat
it up
bam easy
see I'm a gamer I've played games before
I know exactly what I'm doing and I know
how I'm doing it
nice
excellent it's Pizza Time
good god I'm an animal I just work that
down that pizza was pretty good now I
should take a shower before going to bed
this is a quick tip this is a fun fact
if you ever want to heat a pizza
properly either use an air fryer or an
oven or you just grease up a skillet a
little bit and you pop it in the pan
honestly you don't even need to grease
it because the oil from the pizza will
heat it will grease itself and it'll
just like cook it'll be almost as good
as it was just don't let it burn unless
you like that which I do sometimes what
am I doing going to bed I thought we
were talking about pizza
that is a disgustingly dirty shower oh
sweet shower cut scene I was hoping
actually I was hoping for this I imagine
this is where those good reviews came in
yay
I'll clean time to go to bed
wow
anything different
who do you think you are you think you
could do that
no
you notice a reflection some
understanding
well that can't be good
zoinks you turn around and see a large
man staring at you with a gray smile on
his face his horse breathing Echoes
throughout the room the man is holding
the decapitated head of a woman thought
several recent disappearances come to
mind in a cold chill runs up your spine
I tackle him I eat his teeth
and the next moment the man Fades away
just as suddenly as he appeared okay
that's weird
you must be more tired than you thought
if you're starting to hallucinate and
maybe eating that pizza before going to
bed was not the best of ideas I once ate
10 day old meatloaf that I made handmade
my grandma's Meatloaf I did not put it
in an airtight container it was in the
fridge admittedly but it was not in an
airtight container I ate it anyway it
had like some white fuzz on it but I
thought if I cooked it out I uh I'd be
okay I puked so hard I broke blood
vessels in my eyes and you might be
thinking oh man was this back in college
nah this was last year
I'm just stupid anyway time for bed time
for me to get it oh oh I could oh maybe
I could play a few rounds whoa
it's bright and or cold outside
I saw something bad all right bedtime
sure that
that man with the decapitated head of a
woman won't be standing over my door I'm
sure I'll be fine
foreign
welcome
to nightmare of decay
oh god oh yes my freaking head
goddamn I'm amazing I'm a freaking
animal a down that pizza I head-butted
my way out of a coffin I'm ready to roll
I'm ready to rock
foreign
what's going on over here
who's screaming for what anyway I know I
know how to get out of here
oh looks like you need to find another
way out of this place I know the key to
this lock
smash my brain out into this into The
Ether I wish that was an option here in
this moment not in real life actually
that's not what I wish
probably that scream is from everyone
who has to open all the doors in this
building with their forehead you get
sick of it after
hi
hello sorry I was making a bad joke how
are you oh my goodness I wish I had
pizza to give you
oh wow
all right you take care of yourself
oh
I I noticed it already uh naturally
intelligent eyes hello all right
can't greet you and strangely enough you
can understand what it's saying
looks like the nightmare is claimed yet
another victim
you talk a lot like the the news anchor
many have been brought here against
their will only to meet a terrible end
one way or another no one has ever
managed to escape alive the cat pauses
to lick you up and down almost as if to
appraise you of your worth
seems unimpressed
I screw you too I wonder how long you'll
be able to survive for not long if I had
to make a guess oh yeah
well I already did the head butting
thing but I suppose
nah I'll spare you it'll be fun to see
how you meet your end in this horrible
place that's what you get maybe one of
the monsters will get you or maybe
you'll go insane and end yourself well I
need to get going good luck stranger try
not to die too fast
okay bye
fine oh bye a knife oh I noticed it
already
I'm way too ahead of you game so I know
my objective and this is my mission put
up a mission statement grab knife kill
demon inside the nightmare stop the
Decay boom if I can do those I'll be a
real YouTuber someday all I have to do
is play the best goddamn nightmare of
decay of my life yeah
to bra I would break it if I hit it with
something
where's my brain
[Music]
I'm amazing I'm a goddamn animal here's
his hair again so well this is obvious I
just gotta follow the blood and I'm
gonna find where I need to go
damn the crazed butt stabber was me all
along
except I'm completely
scene
oh what the hell is that yeah
oh yeah oh my gosh oh hey hey hey you
don't head butt me
I had but you that's what I thought
inspect mutilated body of a man he's
been partially eaten and stabbed very
strange got a key got a gun love that
who needs a gun when you get a knife
stuck and won't budge what about this
never mind go back the way I can yeah
okay so you do slow down when you stab I
gotta be mindful of that it very much is
like Resident Evil hope you guys don't
think I'm making fun of this write down
in the comments if you think I'm making
fun of this game because I'm not
it's actually you can't really write
down
because I just told you what it is the
truth is unless you disagree there'll be
a poll there won't be a poll I'm sorry
I'm just lying to you
or am I
where am I
am
oh
well that's Andy
whole left shift while moving it doesn't
seem like I am unless uh unless because
I'm injured I can't exactly
cue to consume okay let's put that in
two and this is one got it love that so
two for gun one for knife
all right let's do this
wow this looks
suspicious
that looks suspicious
that looks a little suspicious
oh yeah all right
I've tried everything and I'm out of
options
William has been acting strangely ever
since we moved into this manner he's
been spending all his time in the
basement doing God knows what I've tried
asking him about it but he became angry
and confrontational I fear we may be
drifting apart I hate this place we
never should have come here
I agree
why did you come here do you live here
doors locked the shape of a spade has
been carved into the lock is that so
shape of a spade huh
cool good to know I'm sure that will
oh it's just the shadows I'm sure
that'll be very useful later
I'll try to remember it wow mini game
yes pellet gun
I'm so down give
I'm ready
I am
Wham I'm the best
I'm so God damn good
holy [ __ ]
oh I gotta let it aim
goddamn
nailed it I love going into a haunted
house and then immediately playing the
nearest carnival game
I mean that's what it is right this is
just a haunted Carnival
what
over 200 yeah
I'm an animal
I can't be stopped oh yes
yes oh the extra time and with the extra
points
[Music]
oh 229 229 try that try that will you oh
oh lock pick I did need that thank you
and I have a pellet gun I get to take
this with me now
I earned this I earned this I'm going to
keep that on three I don't think it
probably doesn't do much damage but you
know it is what it is let's try this I
have it so why not
oh that is Andy Dynamite God damn I'm
loaded to the tits
what about this Wham unlimited oh my God
I love it I probably could have stabbed
that though
but even so still love it unlimited ammo
I bet it does nothing to a zombie but I
will take it freaking save my bro this
is all I'm having a blast playing this
I'm having a blast playing this but I
know that you guys are probably looking
for more Spooks so uh that's why I had
lyxian put in a jump scare there and one
right here
by there lyxian I mean just like it at a
random point just like a minute or two
ago unless you didn't do it yet
and then everyone's like well we didn't
get a jump scare before and I hit him
with it now
coined shaped indents old farmer tired
of a day of hard labor falls asleep
under the shade of a tree while his
loyal dog watches over him love that
love that
love that all right don't know what
that's about but I love it okay man I am
just so loaded to the tits with ammo
goddamn animal
who wants some whoa hey stop
stop all right I warned you
I warned you
whoa well that's not good
stop
I don't think the pellet gun probably
does anything
but it's good for shooting objects
whoa didn't know that opened that's
interesting
here
if I reload do I lose ammo no I'm
amazing
yeah that probably doesn't do anything
ah fine
I don't know where you were trying to go
bro but it did not work out for you
oh you want one more how about a knife
hey yeah oh
got him
still moving he's still moving stop
moving oh you're bleeding
how do zombies bleed how does that work
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
dumb waiter memo what does it say the
damn dumb waiter is broken again I was
sending up the pantry key to the second
floor and the platform got stuck in the
shaft on the way up not no one could get
into the pantry until the stupid lift is
fixed Lord William will be furious maybe
dropping something heavy into the shaft
from the second floor will be enough to
Deluge it but probably not God I love
writing angry notes to myself
love it hello so the scullery door is
locked interesting
I don't know what scullery means you
know that cat was wrong I'm having a
blast I don't want to end myself the
door of the pantry the faint stench of
rotting meat is coming from behind it
and also a jump scare good God that was
spooky after a moment a rough voice
suddenly calls out to you from the other
side someone there please I need help
can you say that again
I've accidentally locked myself in here
and I can't get back out
while I've been stuck in here my
precious collection has been rotting
away I must escape so I can add fresh
toys to it
please we can help each other you wish
to get in and I wish to get out I don't
you don't know that I wish to get in key
to the door should be somewhere in the
man there's a large Blue key with the
word Pantry carved into it please
interesting flexing is rotting away whoa
hey hey calm down is that the chef oh my
God can I have your hat oh there's it's
not now there's more people to have it I
thought it was unique
Jesus Christ get back oh my God we're
doomed
I'll headbutt you I'll do it
oh
hey stop fall down and die
that was pretty good all right well
you're all dead now
so that's what you get for that oh oops
I meant to go back to the other area not
yet here
any zombies get back up no okay also the
ominous amount of blood coming out from
the pantry also is a little suspicious
but
we're bloody sack
what a bloody sack that's surprisingly
heavy
I have no idea what to do with that head
empty no clue not a clue wouldn't know
the first thing to do with that one
boy howdy I hope someone doesn't solve
the answer before I can get to it acid
recipe
to the Dark Descent a little inspiration
here wait oh and access to some areas of
the manner has been obstructed by a
strange fleshy growth Lord William has
tasked me with finding a solution to the
tissue I've discovered that a mixture
containing equal amounts of linoleum
odessan and aquavarum can be used to
create a corrosive acid that can
dissolve the fleshy growth and regain
access to previously obstructed areas
and I you know I just gotta replay
amnesia the Dark Descent oh it even
looks like it oh even this looks oh it's
just like God damn that's nice
I could probably just put this here for
now it my God that just struck a memory
for me this game is like a mixture of a
whole bunch of different memories that's
great I love it
fantastic
super cool oh it's one right back here
oh God I could have saved myself some
time
okay but I need to get up to the second
floor to open the pantry and also
there's probably other things on the
second floor that I need to do stop by
save uh head butts some paintings go
upstairs this is a really nice
experience I I really like it it's fun
it's reminiscent of so many little
things here and there they're just
making me happy
oh I'm not happy anymore
oh no not happy not happy not happy
oh [ __ ] not happy oh I'm even less happy
oh I'm very sad actually oh
oh
man I'm sad why would you make me do
that oh I guess I didn't have to I could
have run away
oh I guess this would have been me if I
didn't
oh
I'm sad now if you're sad too let me
know in the comments you know what else
is sad I never played any of the
Resident Evil Village extra modes I
always did that before for the other
ones God I can't wait for that DLC
frick
God I want to please Lady D I know that
there are many many other parts of that
DLC but really that is the only one that
I am excited about have I shown you all
the the boobie mouse pads that Amy's
gotten me
yeah
yeah
and I need to find a cabin key that I
don't have
that's okay it's all right uh guys
remember you gonna like oh I see I
didn't like it
I'm sad again all right so let's drop
something heavy on this bad never mind I
didn't think I wanted to do that anyway
I changed my mind about all of it in
fact I don't ever want to be a part of
it again
yeah so there must be something that
I've missed there's got to be a key is
there a key in the coffin did I ever
turn around inspect I woke a bit of
coffee now I get there
where's that damn cat
oh right of course there was other doors
in this hallway I'm dumb I'm dumb
that's why
are you no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
[Music]
no no no no hi King's bust is the bust
of a kingly man dressed in armor
hell yeah
oh yeah it is okay but what does that
have to do with me
interesting
again very Amnesia Vibes very
very Resident Evil vibes
present the king with his Golden Crown
and defeat his loyal guards to open the
way forward
okay so you guys are things so I don't
have a crown
and I don't have a way forward
and I can't beat guards that are not
actually guards so I gotta make them
alive I gotta figure out a way to bring
things uh bring inanimate objects to
life which will be uh that'll be a task
you I'm shooting at something that I
probably shouldn't be shooting at good
thing it's a pellet gun huh
what in the hell
no God that's terrifying okay that
actually scared me interesting I'm
putting Dynamite on five because screw
you
oh frick that oh man for some reason
that that just like brought me back to
when I used to play like there was some
it was not Cry of Fear this is I think
this is before I even did YouTube there
was like some Half-Life mod that was a
scary game that was not Cry of Fear I
don't think this is part of my channel
this is like something else entirely
oh here they come
all right here we go I don't know how
far I throw
yes oh that was effective
and YouTube
nice all right this goes on
let's put this three in this four
and that Dynamite was good uh even if it
just killed two that was better than
shooting a bunch I think probably but
there I bet there was going to be a
bigger group that I would have been
better off using that for but it's too
late because I've had the problem in the
past where I don't use items as I should
and I just um I sit around with my thumb
up my ass hoping that I could have used
it someday but I didn't oh no look out
behind you
oopsies
all right well that didn't help me a lot
well nothing there maybe we'll try the
other bathroom
yeah peek-a-boo oh God it's a jump scare
oh and a safe spot
perfect
oh no is that creepy Rising ambient
Ambiance oh no we better watch out
there's some spooky Happening Here
hey you're supposed to be okay you are
it's awfully convenient Bang
the goddamn shotgun is awesome
I wish pellet gun was as good
but it's not
wow that took a while unsolved
environmental puzzles can be reset by
exiting and re-entering the area all
right I'll get to it in a second shape
of a club this place is Big there's a
big spot push
oh what are you doing step ladder oh
where am I pushing it to
can't even tell
oh this is the puzzle that needs to be
re reset right okay we got a clock
puzzle oh that's a spade
I know that
Club still okay and then this clearly
this is just heavy bag
bloody sack slap that bad boy down there
boom done easy peasy
but doing good all right great that's
perfect ah and that's where that's
supposed to be okay interesting
so if I push this this way and that way
yeah oh God I'm so strong you know I'll
probably make more progress if I didn't
push with my face but uh it is what it
is
screw let's see where it goes climb
through vent
when you put it like that when you got
like an option like that that don't seem
like something that I'm interested
yet
oh
look out behind you you gotta watch out
oh no this is the only way out
yeah everyone else's Doom music kicks
yeah Alexian put do music in there
everyone else's death
prom
um
who
oh
no you you dead
oh I knew it
are you dead
oh how did I know almost like I've
played these games before
oh no it was alive all along
you know what else was all along your
brains on the wall
s what are you doing
hello
did I just shoot did that cat just go
over there and step on a landmine what
happened
what happened to the cat cat you all
right yo you okay ah hi how you doing
don't mind the shotgun Point directly
are you
thanks for freeing me from that washing
machine who knows how long I would have
been stuck in there if you hadn't come
along I saw something shiny in the
machine and I went in to get it but the
lid closed on me and I couldn't get back
out I managed to get the shiny thing
that was inside since you saved me I'll
give it to you here take it maybe you
can find a use for it
thank you it's a coin of a dog
isn't it isn't it a coin of a dog of
course it is oh I killed those things
you guys seen a zombie in here you seen
a zombie anywhere
me neither okay
anyway
every time I pull out the shotgun just
like kick up just like a second of Doom
music
foreign
needs to be used not every time you know
just like
oh that's pedal gun
nice
all right
perfect
I'm done here what did I get coin
coin let me look at coin
let me look closer at coin
yeah it's a jump scare
I think this might be the last thing
here uh unlocked oh this must go outside
okay so I'll Circle back and I'll go in
that vent now
I bet the vent goes downstairs I bet
it's a shorty cut
that is one of those shorty Cuts I'm
gonna go downstairs now climb through
vent yes
please
oh shorty cat with some goodies because
I went down here and not just loop back
around is that low down them is that oil
lanolim lenalum
loud down him God I miss him
oh my freaking God no thank you what in
the hell
are you kidding me you kidding me right
now you kidding me you kidding me right
now you kidding me with that crap you're
gonna spook me like that huh you gonna
spoke me give me The Spook huh is that
what you're gonna do
are you gonna do that oh no no
[Music]
this is too many to fight why would I
even bother with him I'm not gonna
bother with you why would I bother with
you
hello Pantry man
how are you good
uh-huh yeah you mean
I don't have it yet ah my brain really
took a while to process there you mean
this Pantry key dude
oh you found a hurry and open the door
my collection is rotting away as we
speak
okay
to work adding fresh toys
oh no oh no mysteriously the key is
disappeared and there's no sign of that
person that was locked inside the room
are you sure about that
are you sure about that I can't Crouch a
nice ass
oh nice
spleen nice
the word Pantry has been carved onto the
lock
well that's unfortunate
a held body inspector a young woman has
been impaled on the wooden Staker
expression is the eerily peaceful
despite the gruesome manner of her death
she is clutching a coin
Don't Mind If I Do
[Music]
you brought the coin from her dead hands
a moment later the English crying of a
woman that goes through out the boundary
and a cold chill runs up your spine as
you sense a malicious presence in the
center of the room
oh no delicious presence
you're a fresh toy whoa oh ow okay that
was rude oh I should have put help on uh
I should have put Health on my uh my hot
bar
yeah right take this
how about some of this oh God no please
miss me
oh God he wants to kiss me ow all right
what about one of these
ow
oh no oh God that's not what I expected
any who got this now that was really
something
I'm glad that happened I'm glad I
experienced that face first I I'd like
to think that I finished him off with a
headbutt but I know better I did not
Hello peekaboo yes please don't mind if
I do right so I got three keys which
means that I can go out and do the
dinner thing with the fireplace and the
dog and I can put something in here jar
lanolin there we go that's good enough
for me I'll come back when I got more
saying a tree goes here and are you
saying that old man is sitting under the
tree and are you saying a dog watch is
over him
oh well would you look at that that is a
club key and that goes upstairs I
remember that it'd probably be easier to
go upstairs by going outside and saving
and then going around the other way and
then I should heal
I am a gaming God
I saved in the wrong spot I'm a tragedy
I'm Travis I'm a travesty I'm I'm
repugnant I am horrible
I should never be forgiven Wham oh I am
the worst
I do music sound I'm pretty uh Out Of
Tune at the moment hey you got something
on your face there
hey you got something on your face there
hey you got something on your face here
all right
hello
I'm in the club room
wasn't there another side of this that
was also the wrong room uh
yeah not my room uh not my room I'm
gonna say that not
not my room
not my room
hello hi bye
wasn't this also Club yes it was okay I
was not crazy about that I thought I was
turns out I wasn't I should use some
physical because I have the ammo for it
hello
where are you going nice try Belle
well this is now you've played pool oh
it's a clue eight and two got it okay
eight and two man I'm too smart for this
game
oh what's that for Clocky uh well you
need that I suppose
hell again
okay eight and two well eight ten more
specifically is what that would be so
810 I have the clock key I smash that
open grab what's in there that goes
downstairs so I'm going to use the clock
key on that
it's going to go 8 10.
all right here we go
easy easy
God damn all right I gotta go in here
and I gotta see what the hell that was
all about is that the weird flashy
growth that I need
I'm gonna grab a suit
[Music]
I'm spending all this time in the
basement and Lady Irma has fallen into a
deep depression over his strange
Behavior it all seems to have started
after he asked me and a few other
servants to install a wardrobe over a
large hole in the basement in the weeks
afterwards it's almost as if he has
become a different person aloof and
quick to anger Lord William has our
ordered us to meet him in the basement
again tomorrow I wonder what strange
task he'll have us do this time
I don't know but you know my objectives
kick ass what was the other one and then
head butt the uh owner of the manor
those were definitely the objectives hi
I don't want to there's a fleshy growth
on the wall with a large hole in the
center a creature with glowing red eyes
is peering out of the hole
hello stranger would you mind doing a
favor for me God I don't want to do a
favor for the creature
you seem trustworthy
thank you stranger I've tried asking
others but they would only scream and
run away the moment I greeted them how
rude you see I'm an
I'm an avid collector of human heads uh
okay well you started off this real nice
the tortured expression of death on
their face fills me with great joy uh
they do call me a bringer of joy not all
heroes
have heads but my collection is flawed I
really recently realized that something
is missing all the heads in my
collection are male and I have no female
heads I wish to correct this imbalance
quality if you can bring me three female
human heads and place them on the tray
I've provided I will reward you for your
troubles
yeah what if I don't
I'm just gonna just conjecturizing
theorizing what if I don't
what if I uh
what if I don't I have a key that I
could go see what it do and uh that
would be different than uh trying to do
that to be perfectly honest I don't know
where the hell I'd even find
those things where would anybody nobody
would ever ever
who could
not me that's for sure that's for sure
anyway gotta go in the Spade hello
that was spooky
good thing that was properly jump scared
or else I would never have noticed you
good thing I got more shotgun ammo
and a knife
take that and that I'm one of these oh
I'm in danger oh you heard a lot oh this
is bad
well that could have gone
worse I'm still alive [ __ ] tried to
kill me but you can I'm an animal I'm
unstoppable on flap oh
all right
I'm gonna scrub that one for my brain
[Music]
okay all right one of these these swords
aren't all the same interesting
interesting
yeah interesting
yeah Square shaped hole okay so one of
these guys has a square penis from one
of these guys has a hexagonal penis
I gotta find out who's going in who's
hole
so can I push you I can interesting
see the thing is I don't exactly know
how I can turn you
and it's clearly a puzzle so
let's see what happens
turns out nothing
[Music]
all right that did not do what I was
hoping it would do okay so I'm gonna
come back when I need that
um because clearly I don't have what I
need just there but I will eventually
okay so this has been a big waste of my
time because I can't even go that way
this place big this place big
this place big where did I come from
oh yeah I came from this way
all right big double doors it is
Library hi
hello
are you
okay the chanting I thought at first I
had friends but the chanting really
shows that um maybe not so much you have
a gun I have a gun they're really doomed
now
foreign
still how can I shoot you if you don't
hold still ah
at least they seem to have the right
attitude about you know their odds
it really you really do need a gun to be
able to hold your own in this place
got him
all right well only a few bullet wounds
and I'm A-Okay all right so Library
means that there's probably going to be
some kind of a book puzzle like
something that I've got a the book I've
got to pull off or there's got to be
like
welcome
no I'm not gonna die to you because I
have a shotgun out
yeah that's what you get that's what you
get that's what you get
that's what you get that's got me I did
not I was not expecting a mimic
that uh I should have known should have
known didn't have my guard up didn't
have my instincts up Square shaped hole
got it I need a square shaped Peg which
I do not have where does this go
not
last time either you're tough also I
missed a lot oh man that took way too
many bullets
also you lost your arm back there time
to amp back up into gamer mode I'm
clearly like going down Diamond carved
in how many keys are here
so many little puzzles
[Music]
[Music]
um
now I can come back to that this is a
clue I can I can come back to that
though I I don't need to do that right
now
I
I yeah all right fine I'll take this
over the other thing what do we have
inspects the toilets clogged with
disgusting filth the stench coming from
it is extremely pungent that's great you
notice that there's something stuck in
the toilet oh yeah I do oh you bet I do
reach and get it
head butt time
[Music]
my goodness great oh good square peg
crank uh great good can I Crush these
stupid why not get grosser
more grossness good Bang
oh
gross
hi
oh okay oh this is the other side of the
upstairs he's I should save I should I
should save I should save I got one of
those feelings like I should save you
know what I mean I got a feeling I got
one of those feelies
peekaboo I see you no I don't
hello what are you doing all alone this
corner
what are you doing all over the corner
hmm I could probably lock it with a long
pick good thing I met that mimic
I bet this is gonna pass some goodies oh
there's a safe
of course of course my gamer Instinct
was right but I didn't have the right
timing all right Skye there's nothing
else on this uh upper story that place
that I need to get so I guess I'm all
done here I guess I can go home I won't
solve the mystery of the manor I guess I
gotta find another way out if you know
what I mean
foreign
[Music]
I think it's a corpse
better be of course
oh boy
you mean both bud
oh no but uh oh I needed that the
decapitated body of a middle-aged woman
lays sprawled on top
they sprawled on top of the bed to Trail
the blood is leading from the body
sure of course it is
what has happened to my husband it's
almost like William has become a
completely different person now he even
spent his night down in the basement and
I can't remember the last time we slept
in the same bed together we barely even
speak to each other anymore even more
worrying some servants have gone missing
and strange things have been happening
around the manor just last night I heard
a horrid breathing sound coming from the
Wardrobe kept me up all night I tried to
tell William about it but he just
ignored me and walked away I'm beginning
to fear for my life
can live like this anymore well guess
what
you're right click click okay well you
need to find a key apparently I have the
crank thing so I can crank something I
recently saw a crankable thing
and so I need to go back and I need to
crank that thing I just don't remember
what it was I mean not the room of
knights because that had multiple things
to crank and this is only uh one of them
I need to get this this is it
excellent
oh I have all the the the the spruceies
I got all of them so I can uh douse the
thing that was blocking my way with acid
and it will scream and it will die and
hell maybe it'll work on the thing in
the hole but I'm not gonna try that
because I bet it would be very angry
with me if I did try that all right
let's get this
uh wham wham uh wham wham wham turn it
bam perfect thank you sometimes I missed
just like oh it's like a classic puzzle
I mean there are many games that like
tried to do the classic puzzles but this
like this one is just reminiscent so I
just like I enjoy it and I think I gotta
go back upstairs I think it'd probably
be quicker to go through that doorway
and then go find the thing and then
douse it in acid I think unless I'm
wrong and I might be wrong
that I it's too bad I purged that from
my memory
I think actually if I do go in the Spade
area
was this club I can't remember
was that what the what did I just hear
behind me
hey
all right
great diamonds
this is a great day why do I feel so
uncomfortable about what the hell I
heard in that other room this is not
good
all right anyway I got the diamond so I
go in the Diamond Room I don't imagine
there'd be much more than the diamond
Rim that I need to get into but I'm sure
this game will find more to provide for
me was this the Diamond Room no
damn it what about this one damn it
oh this is the poop dungeon where was
the Diamond Room was it over here
no I'm dumb turns out I'm an idiot where
was that I'm fast forwarding I'm
traveling through time
did it
I was number four
hi
no
don't know
[Music]
[Music]